the epitome of male vanity is in the
summer in the summer in any town you
will see a man an 80 year old man
walking down the street in a tank top or
Worse no shirt at all just strutting
down the sidewalk like an expired
rotisserie chicken
ain't that the truth well comedian Tom
Papa has earned a devoted following for
his stand-up and it's honest take on the
trials and tribulations of everyday life
and while the stage is a great venue for
that material so too are the pages of a
book this week papa is out with his
latest We're All in This Together Jamie
wack spoke with him about his corner of
the comedy world
I travel a lot oh that's tough to take
my friends when I don't get the upgrade
and I'm jammed and coached between two
sumo wrestlers in track suits eating
pretzels like a praying mantis for six
hours Tom Papa is known for his deeply
funny deeply observed truth-telling
about contemporary life for me a good
day now is any day I don't have to
retrieve a username and password
which occasionally puts him at odds with
some contemporary comedy trends
people seem to be chasing Edge you don't
really have an edge except for honesty
yeah the thing that people remark about
all the time is that I'm not as cynical
as comedians typically are but I don't
live that way I don't want to be cynical
I want to be hopeful
through the times and where we're at
right now actually being hopeful is edgy
grown-ups need to kind of know and
they're just regurgitating things
they've said for 50 years
how's work done on still a million bucks
shy of being a millionaire Papa credits
his early days in New York clubs for
helping him find his authentic voice
where he frequently followed comedians
with a different style than his own I
would come out there with my tweed
jacket with elbow patches and try and be
Dave Attell and I would try and tell
dirty jokes and I remember a couple
nights some people looking at me like
what are you doing like what are you
trying to be I think that's the whole
key to Comedy is don't be a fraud they
they know and it's not you Papa's
comedic voice led him to a string of
successful projects we're all fat
you're either really fat kind of fat or
trying not to be fat including stand-up
specials If This Were MTV's cribs we'd
say this is where the magic happens yeah
baby radio and podcast series multiple
projects with director Steven Soderberg
and hosting the first TV series after
Seinfeld from friend and fan Jerry
Seinfeld they're not gonna have a fight
they're in love look at them
the marriage ref
a lot of people recognize me from the
show I felt like it was Jerry's vehicle
and I was kind of along for the ride I
was a co-pilot you know but I always say
my biggest break in comedy was meeting
Jerry I was on stage and he was just
coming back into the clubs and he called
me over to the bar and he's like you're
really funny and I grabbed onto his
coattails and never let go
Papa's own coattails go back to Passaic
New Jersey where he was making people
laugh as early as kindergarten what did
you think you were gonna be did you see
this life for yourself the summer of
seventh grade I heard
two comedy albums Steve Martin let's get
small and George Carlin's Class Clown
and that was the first time I realized
that being funny could be a job and from
that point on that was it I thought I'm
gonna go do that and he did the comedian
has five specials under his belt and has
written three books his latest We're All
in This Together is made up of 37
heartfelt and hilarious essays on Modern
Life I feel that your new book
it is a sort of a tutorial on how to be
a human it is this book really is my
realizing there's a manual to have a
live and jotting down
how I've lived by it in my life and
maybe you should pay attention to it too
many of his stories on the page and on
the stage include his family especially
his wife of 23 years Cynthia a talented
comic and improv artist in her own right
let's do it right now okay hello mama
papa roll with it I'm back in third
grade
no it's nice out the couple met 25 years
ago while performing in New York I know
people talk about this but
I there was like an electrical
charge like I felt something completely
different when I met him and he says the
same thing you know I just found out my
wife doesn't like when I read
you started talking about her very
quickly yeah she thinks oh he's bored
let me tell him a story about my sister
at work
was that good with you well in the very
beginning I was still performing so I
was talking about him so I'm used to it
it's actually stranger for me to hear
people who listen to him on the radio or
the podcast they've been following our
family and sometimes I think should I
talk about them anymore and then people
come up after a show and they're like so
how's everybody doing what's the net
what's next my daughter came into the
kitchen she said Dad we're trying to
watch a movie in the other room and we
can hear you breathing
and of all the material Thomas created
from their shared experience there's a
chapter of the new book that holds a
special meaning to his wife there is a
section in the book called uh will you
go out with me and that that's very
personal to you it is personal to me
because it's sort of
um I don't know there are certain essays
that feel like Love Letters to me it is
both our philosophy on how relationships
should be cherished and I hope that our
girls actually take it to heart as well
yeah a little romance little romance
nothing so cold and calculated and
you're on social media and using dating
apps it's like no go meet their parents
uh take your time be patient and like
every great Storyteller Papa knows how
to end on a powerful note one of my
favorite things in the entire book is
incredibly simple right at the end and
I'm going to paraphrase uh
but it's basically that the goal is to
live a good life yeah what is that
definition to you Tom
you want to feel when you leave the room
when you leave this planet that uh
things were a little better because you
were around right this is all temporary
don't monitor yourself in aggravation
be with good people try and make them
happy have some laughs
and uh
you'll be all right thank you so much
for coming CBS Saturday morning Jamie
wax Los Angeles thank you so much